all right I was pretty honored by this I
have to say
um Media Matters
lists the uh top 10 misinformers in
2022.
well not exactly these are these are
Tucker Carlson's go-to misinformers in
2022.
the top 10 individuals this is a Media
Matters over the past year Fox news's
Tucker Carlson who is being named Media
Matters misinformer of the Year leverage
this platform to amplify the reach of
these 10 individuals as they spread
misinformation they push topics
including bigotry against immigrants in
the lgbtq community misinformation about
covid-19 the war in Ukraine climate
change and general right-wing grievances
so
Tucker Carlson did get the title of
misinformer of the year uh they didn't
even have like any they didn't even list
any runners up I I you know I knew I
wasn't gonna
I probably was you know competing
against Tucker Carlson it was going to
be a tough competition I'm a little bit
disappointed I mean given the fact that
me I do have my own section on the site
that they list on Google so I you know
I'd like to know how many votes I got at
least
But ultimately they gave it to uh to
Tucker Carlson although I was listed as
one of his top misinformers so uh I feel
pretty good about that they listed his
top misinformers Jason Rance Glenn
Greenwald Candace Owens Tulsi gabbard
who's that lives a tick tock Stephen
Miller Alex Berenson Douglas McGregor
and then also Matt Walsh says the daily
wire self-described Theocratic fascists
and anti-trans extremist Matt Walsh was
a frequent guest on Tucker Carlson type
walshow has helped lead a right-wing
campaign of harassment against
Children's Hospitals providing
life-saving gender affirming care to
trans youth that was previously
slandered lgbtq people as groomers was
on the show 12 times
and of course the right wing campaign of
harassment against children's hospitals
that entire campaign consisted of
me and not just me along with lives of
tick tock and Christopher and others
simply pointing out that here hey look
guys look at what these hospitals are
doing
that's that's what harassment is
and this is yet another article you
could read the entire thing and and you
you see lots of people
being labeled misinformer
lots of claims that are labeled
misinformation
and yet they never even try to explain
how or why we're wrong
like what did we say that was wrong
exactly
what claims do we make about hospitals
that was incorrect
but we know of course that on the left
misinformation is uh it's not wrong
information or faulty information it's
simply information that they find
inconvenient that's what it means
and that'll do it for this portion of
the show is move over to the members
block hope to see you there if not talk
to you tomorrow Godspeed
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]